hey youtubers is charlie if you didn't
see it Game of Thrones posted this o
mais teaser video just characters
talking about a charity they're doing
associated with season six but there
were some really cool things that they
teased during so there's going to be a
breakdown of that just give up for
spoilers for everything on the show
that's already happened and everything
in the books that the show has already
done so I'm going to start with the
northern storyline stuff I'm gonna play
this mirror part of the clip here we go
you could find out why we went for an
entire season hint it was pretty much
ago so yeah you know right off the bat
what does that mean well it means that
mirror read is coming back which I think
most of us unofficially assumed like
everybody associated with brands
storyline was put on ice for season five
so we're like well they'll probably all
come back except for Jojen who died at
the end of season four but on the list
of things that I was pretty certain
about the season six would do she was
pretty low like we're really certain
that Daenerys is gonna have a big
Dothraki storyline because she was
captured by those rocky at the end of
season five but me read was kind of left
hanging in the wind or in the roots i
guess i should say with Hodor who is
also coming back even though he doesn't
appear in this teaser when she talks
about the magical place that we have
been she's talking about the royal we of
their party so we have to talk about
with the dynamic of that group is going
to be because the way Dan and Dave were
teasing it around the Emmys and some of
the interviews they've done since then
brain is going to be like Luke Skywalker
in Return of the Jedi almost a complete
Jedi not officially a fully powered
greenseer but one who is almost there
like Luke Skywalker and Return of the
Jedi was calling himself a Jedi even
though they were still a couple things
he had left to do so for all intents and
purposes bran is going to be a total
badass so what does me are gonna do if
her role in the party previously was to
be Joe jeans protector she was Joe Jones
older sister so it had been her job her
entire life to keep an eye on him mostly
because one day he'd be lord of House
read after Howland Reed died who I know
we're still wondering where he is
Howland Reed is still alive somewhere on
the show the show just hasn't addressed
it yet but but then as things start to
go crazy in Game of Thrones when season
1 season 2 pick up Jojen starts to get
the dreams realizes that there's this
higher calling he needs to find brand
and take him to see the last greenseer
so at that point he starts to get weaker
and weaker just like brand got weaker
when he lost the use of his legs mira
officially appoints herself his
protector because he cannot protect
himself so now
you'd assume she'd do the same thing for
brand because even though Hodor is meant
to protect brand really brand is the one
that protects Hodor you get that sense
hooters like this big lovable finger
puppet for brand so technically brand
protects Hodor he can war again to him
now so he can create his own protector
if he needs to so what's been happening
with mirror this whole time especially
like if they need things in that root
system while he's been training with the
last greenseer presumably the children
of the forest that serves the last
korean seer will get whatever they need
so I'm thinking what the show has done
is that they dial the back a little bit
on children of the forest you know
running around with brand outside
because we see him on this horse here
and they'll probably use mirror for a
lot of the support tasks that you would
see children of the forest doing like
going and foraging for food building
shelter things that require higher brain
function that Hodor is not capable of I
know a lot of you're asking about winds
of winter like what does this mean for
that because at the end of Dance with
Dragons it seemed like brain was going
to be stuck under that tree with the
last green stare like in his special
cave for the rest of his life so
naturally no one expects mirror to just
stay under there with him for the rest
of her life especially because in the
books there are more children to the
forest serving the last greenseer but
unless george RR martin reveals some
preview chapters four winds of winter
that explain what's going on with brant
storyline we'll just have to wait till
it comes out to see what's different
from the TV show because it seems like
based on the schedule that George are
Martin is on we'll get all of season six
before wins a winner but we will be
getting wins a winner sometime this year
just not before the spring and the
really interesting thing that unless
something changes brand is not going to
be a POV character in wins a winner so
I'm really interested to see how that
book addresses his storyline the show is
definitely jumping way for their head in
his story because he's a really
important character but if he's not a
POV character then you can't really
address him unless he's doing like rat
rods unless he's going to be like a
narrator type character but you guys let
me know in the comments what do you
think miras role is going to be in brans
group if he's already really powerful
and he has Hodor to warg into if he
needs a protector what about all the
stuff that's going on at the wall what
about the pink letter Ramsey video that
I just did Ramsay snow is going to be
very active in the North taunting who we
think might end up being Jon Snow there
might be a big battle will we see Mira
bran and Hodor involved with that may be
indirectly but I think bran is going
to be more concerned with the night's
king in the army of whites that the
White Walkers have created the wall is
supposed to be the kingdom's first line
of defense against stuff like that but
really bran is the first slide of
defense because he's way for the north
of the wall and now thanks to the green
seer he has a much broader understanding
of what's going on with the White
Walkers and the war for the dawn so we
do see brand getting involved with the
craziness that's going on just south of
the wall you know between Winterfell on
the wall I think it'll only be
indirectly but every once in a while the
show throws us a curveball so just be
prepared for brand to show up places
that you do not expect him next big
thing that appears in this Loras with a
shaved head we are offering you and a
friend a chance to fly over to Belfast
and visit the game of thrones said he'll
get a chance to meet the cast watch this
film and even sit on the Iron Throne
there are a number of reasons why he
could have shaved his head but it might
have something to do with the faith
storyline if you noticed like all of the
faith militant have shaved their heads
so she had to shave her head before the
walk of shame he could have shaved his
head for that or because he's done
filming he could have just shaved it
because the actor wanted to shave it but
I just saw a lot of people were freaking
out because he had really short hair
it's not like kit harington hair watch
it's not quite the same thing there are
a number of more plausible reasons to
explain why Loras could have short hair
but a next big character Nymeria sand I
can show you the best way to get sound
out of your shoes hint you ask the
costume department for a new pet
confirming that we're gonna see some
more sand snake related things we don't
know exactly where she's going to go
you're gonna do book things or if
they're gonna change her story line a
bunch but I'm kind of hoping that they
circle back around and do nigeria's book
plot from Dance with Dragons way way
back in season two when Tyrion was still
hand to the king he gave Prince Doran a
seat on the small Council in exchange
for help with Marcella in the Battle of
Blackwater Bay on season four of the
show Oberyn Martell came as Prince
Durant proxy so now there's a vacant
Dornish seat on the small Council so I'm
hoping that they send Nymeria sand and
she just gets a bunch of scenes with
those King's Landing characters I know
you guys are wondering when the first
real trailer is going to come I'm
expecting it in the next couple of weeks
HBO always changes the way they market
game of thrones every year just a little
bit
they've been doing a lot of little
teasers so I think they'll probably do
that week to week for the next couple of
weeks till they actually drop season six
footage I know that Super Bowl is coming
there's always a bunch of Super Bowl
trailers usually the trailers you see it
super bowls are four really big movies
not for TV shows or whatever they end up
dropping I will totally do a video for
it so be sure and subscribe to get
everything if there's any special bonus
videos that you guys want just let me
know in the comments below giveaway time
yeah everybody loves giveaways
congratulations to Mario Diaz you in
last week's Amazon giveaway please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so i can get your contact
details I know you guys are really ready
for season six to be here don't worry
they'll be dropping a bunch more teasers
in the next couple of weeks wait guys
wait for that you can click here for all
my Game of Thrones season 6 teaser
videos they've actually been a bunch of
them so far and you can click here for
my last big Suicide Squad trailer video
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you